whether you love it hate it I've never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up Georgia governor
nathan Deal who signed into law a bill
that requires drug tests for welfare
applicants and the North Carolina Board
of Dietetics and nutrition which
threatened blogger Steve cook seat with
diabetes warrior net with jail time
after he touted his success using the
Paleo diet and urged others to follow
his lead turns out that counts as the
practice of Dietetics our nutrition
without a license and that's a violation
of state law but there can be only one
nanny of the month and this time it's
the Brazilian city of vitoria conquista
republic school officials are tracking
kids with GPS devices in an effort to
cut down on hookie officials had
embedded locator chips into the t-shirts
of grade school students they call them
intelligent uniforms and they use
technology similar to the kind that's
used to track pets by next year the
chips are expected to be keeping tabs on
all of the city's 43,000 school kids
said one official I believe we may be
setting the trend because we have
received many requests about how our
system works check back next month for
more examples of busybodies minded your
own business
you